the Joe Rogan experience he's very very
keenly aware of the mental battles that
are going on and how much visualization
is important in meditating Lani Bassam
Lambie Bassam yeah guy was a competitive
target shooter and he spent more time
practicing in his head than he did
practicing Wow more time visualizing
that works that really does work does
something because when I was like I said
when I was hurt for the rampage fight
like I was in training camp I would I
would do visualize a lot how would you
do it I would just sit there and now
we're just kind of like I will go
through moves in my mind and I'll go
through techniques and I would just kind
of go over and over again the techniques
in my mind I'll also do scenarios where
I fight in almost every single situation
like I find myself you know losing and
then finding a way to come back after
I've been rocked you know he was trying
to find out myself just mentally working
through it
mentally working on through it almost
every single fight like I'll go round by
round really yeah going round by round
and now just like okay I'll set up the
scenario okay I'll come on I catch him
with a punch and then I'm just imagining
what happens after that and then I put
myself in adversity adversary' adversity
every single time I can as much as I can
so then that way I find myself always
you know I get myself out of adversity
sometimes I just find myself just
smoking them but there's always these
different mental mental games and me
just doing something and executing and
always just doing it right so it's
almost like you were fighting without
having a fight yeah you were getting the
experience of fighting in your head by
just visualizing it mm-hmm
would you set a certain amount of time
that you would do it um nah I would just
I would just I would just go with the
flow you know I had my wrestling coach
in college Tom Minko he was always he
was always on like I was out like I get
nervous I get nervous I don't know what
to do with the nervousness and he says
well he says you nervous because you
thinking too much about about about it
he said just just think about executing
don't think about the outcome just think
about executing your technique and just
only think about executing your
technique and how it feels to complete
the perfect execution of the technique
you hit the pad and hit that and it
sounds that you know they hear that pop
you know how does that feel you know
become attached to how you feel when you
execute something mmm and then that's
what you start to base your fight off of
you know how you feel when you execute
versus all the things that can happen if
something goes wrong hmm yeah it's it's
really interesting to see the different
strategies that people employ in order
to like focus the mind you know so many
different fighters have different ways
of doing it some fighters like to
meditate some fighters like to shadowbox
their way through scenarios almost like
they are thinking about how the fights
gonna go down while they're like slow
motion doing things you know I would I
would get in a mirror sometimes I'll
yell in a mirror I like yelling fear
like I would I would just you know I
would I would get into it because a lot
of times I would get so nervous that
I'll be like oh my god I just don't want
to freeze out there I just don't run
trees you know so I would like that's
that's part of the reason why I started
twisting my nipples nipples before the
fight and that was just to kind of do
something stupid and silly right but
then it would allow me to just kind of
relax I'm like well I'm not gonna
embarrass myself any worse than that I
remembered you always wanting to ask you
about yeah do that I was just doing just
like you know embarrass myself worse
than a Scott George you should do that
should - George would do it yeah George
that George is doing because you know he
I don't know I think he didn't like the
way his nipples look when he first came
on the show people don't like puffy
nipples nipples on guys are weird things
anyway you know he looks even worse yeah
well some dudes have like big areolas
yeah the real embarrassing I want to
take their shirt I want to take your
shirt off with a big area
the girl it doesn't matter at all but a
guy with a big areolas like whoa what's
happening here Mary what do you what's
going on there today just hanging out
pornographic that's what it is - for
dudes when they get fat that's a bummer
man when they development it's no hey
that's a bummer
and when they don't care they could slap
you would have messed up like terrible
terrible terrible oh my gosh I'm just
glad I didn't have nothing like that
I did get big big they have some some
booby weight but not not that day
[Laughter]
[Applause]